my buddy from the worldwide leader in
sports with brackets we've got brackets
uh back here on the rich eisen show is
jay bilas how are you jay
i'm doing great rich how are you i am
loving the fact that it's the first time
in two years i've had brackets in my
hands so that's terrific
i'm enjoying that is a good thing i know
that is a good thing i know that so
uh what's your impressions of what you
what you have in your hands and
what what do you what do you think
deserves spotlighting
jay bilas well first of all you have no
idea what i have in my hands right now
other than the phone okay unless you're
hands-free but
very good yeah okay i thought that i
thought the bracket was pretty balanced
honestly there was not a whole lot of
griping going on
part of that might be that we're so
grateful to have the tournament back yes
uh that we're not you know we're not
taking a swing at the committee
indiscriminately trying to knock them
out but the other part
i think is that they did a good job um
usually you can look at
uh the regions and say well this is the
hardest region by far and this you know
this team got a break
and i didn't feel that way about any of
the regions and honestly rich i didn't
feel
that any of the teams that got left out
got screwed um
you know most of them just weren't all
that good i mean louisville could make a
pretty
good case uh because i think covet
derailed them more than anything
right but but honestly i didn't feel
like uh like a bunch of these teams got
job
and you know every year it feels that
way and it didn't feel that way this
year so overall i think the committee
did a pretty good job
maybe it was the distancing that did it
that they uh they couldn't they couldn't
talk one another in the past
okay so we can actually say there is a
benefit to not being in the same room uh
i dig that
um so uh what what did you think of the
one seeds i mean
i guess were we talking chalk here
that's what we all expected to get the
one seeds the way that it all went down
despite my alma mater losing a couple of
their last
three games what do you think yeah those
were no-brainers um
you know the only question mark you had
was was how would they treat michigan
with isaiah livers out but my sense is
with this sort of stress reaction thing
that there's a good chance he'll be back
if he's not back um they're still very
good
but they're not elite offensively
they're just very good offensively like
they they could have won um you know
they could have beaten
uh one in the tournament uh the big ten
tournament without him but they had a
shot to win
against ohio state at the end um but
with him
they're they're they're they're a lead
on the offensive end but they got a they
got a pretty
difficult draw to play without him if
they wind up
it's going to be a really good 8-9 game
between st bonaventure and lsu
if they wind up going against lsu lsu
has got some athletes man
and they are actually starting to guard
people that was a problem early in the
year they didn't guard anybody
and uh and they got beat several times
by teams that shouldn't beat him
but uh but they're playing now and
they've got nba talent they've got some
really good players cam thomas is a is
an nba player
so um i guess which which one seed do
you think has the best chance to win
if you think the the ones are going to
make it i'll give you the floor on that
one then
yeah i don't think all the ones are
going to make it um that's only happened
once in the history of the tournament
back in 2008
when all four number ones uh made it so
you know i i think somebody will get
tripped up um you know given that livers
is out i hate to
say this to you but in michigan but i
think gonzaga is the best team and i
think they're gonna win it
um and and they got a great draw like
they're two three and
the two three and four seeds in their
region in the west they've already
played they beat the hell out of each
one of them and two of them are
compromised now
um uh virginia and kansas they both uh
had to drop out of their conference
tournaments with this covet stuff and
i don't think i don't think them
quarantining for a week
uh both virginia and uh and kansas it
may not hurt them that bad but it ain't
gonna make them better
so uh so i think gonzaga's gotta you
know had a good break there
how do you think the ncaa's handling uh
covert 19 and that situation to use your
phrase there what do you think
well overall i think everything has been
good
i mean it just goes against what they've
always said they're about
i mean the idea that you know remember
when the pandemic first hit
uh you know they kind of came down with
this hoity-toity thing about no students
on campus no college sports and then
they looked at each other
wait a minute if we don't have students
on campus we got to make money here
they said all right forget that no
students on campus uh online education
means students are technically on campus
therefore we're going to play
and then and then they said including
the big ten commissioner the pac-12
commissioner said
we will not play in bubbles that we are
not the nba we are college sports
and we've kept the players in complete
and total isolation during the season
and they're in in a very real bubble in
indianapolis now
i don't have any problem with it but but
it it's
pretty odd that the nfl the nba and
major league baseball
can play and let their players go home
at night and see their families
but we can't pull this off in college
sports and uh
and so i i don't i don't particularly
care for the choice
the the quote-unquote choice that's been
given to the players of
if you want to play here's what you're
going to do when
the coaches and staff were able to go
home to their families all year
and and they were the biggest threat to
the players getting covet where the the
staff
but but i get it in the in the bubble
like you know the
the about this rich the selection
committee uh
nobody in that bubble is allowed out of
their hotel unless they are going to the
arena
so even the selection committee uh they
can't leave their hotel go get a cup of
coffee go on a walk
and could you imagine if uh if one of
the so you know one of those
administrators somebody snaps a picture
of them you know the starbucks
cup in their hands walking without a
mask or something everybody go nuts
because the players are being you know
quarantined this way
jay bella's here on the rich eisen show
uh
also odd one would say uh is that your
alma mater duke is not
in this tournament how would you
describe their
season i mean if somebody just came from
another planet knowing what duke is
all about and what what it has been all
about certainly on the court and
and in the classroom etc so on and so
forth
how would you describe duke's 20
20 2021 season jay bilas well i wouldn't
have to explain to extraterrestrials
duke or coach k
they they i think the entire known
universe knows all about coach k
um but i i do think that this is a year
this has been a year where duke got to
the duke fans got to feel what it's like
to be everybody else
and and you know most teams out there
were were like duke they're they're
they're good and they're good on certain
days and they can beat anybody on
a given day but they just don't have
that many given days and
and they're gonna have three game losing
streaks and do
duke experience what it's like for for
the rest of the world to be on the
bubble
and the fans don't remember that because
uh it hadn't happened in
in 35 years and uh
so they're different like duke and
kentucky had the number one number two
recruiting classes this year
but recruiting classes are different and
uh and there was no zion there was no
anthony davis there were no tied players
like that
that were transformational superstars
those stars went to oklahoma state kate
cunningham went to ufc evan mobley went
to gonzaga jalen suggs
so there will there were one and two
because they had a number of good
players
rather than having superstar talent and
the guys they have are gonna be really
good
and and a number of them are going to
play in the nba
they're just not ready for this to be
load carriers in the spotlight right
this second
and that's been unusual for duke and
kentucky um
but the you know the tournament will go
on without them they'll be everybody be
fine
but i think it's it's good for the fans
to recognize there is a difference
between
uh some of these super talents that
they've had and uh and guys that are
just really really you know really good
players
so why do you think so many others were
talking about duke's business with jalen
johnson
jay what do you think well i i i think
that whole jalen johnson thing
um i i think became somewhat of a
controversy because
uh you had people that were saying
they're better off without him as if he
was the problem
and and he wasn't like when it's funny
rich when he was injured
and people were going what's wrong with
duke the first thing everybody said was
they need jalen johnson back
and when he came when he came back the
first game back he came off the bench he
had 24 points
15 rebounds seven assists four blocks
and zero turnovers and they lost by a
bucket
and and everybody's like man they gotta
get the ball to jaylen johnson more
jaylen johnson jayla johnson's this
but when he decided to leave and and
and quit whatever you want to call it
opt out
first of all when when people say my way
of the highway don't be surprised when
somebody takes the highway
and that's what college basketball says
to these guys is my way of the highway
and so he decided to quit i don't agree
with the decision i think he would have
been better off sticking
it out but but he he kind of got
attacked honestly
and i think it was fine to say hey was
it the right decision for him to opt out
you know what is that the best for his
future is that the best for his mba
status is that the best for him as a
player
and a teammate and a person that's all
fair game and we should discuss that
stuff
but when somebody says uh he was hurting
them
come on man that's not true that's just
the system saying hey if you do this
the rest of you if you do this if you
opt out of a bowl game
if you decide you're gonna opt out here
we're coming after you and we're coming
after your character and i just think
that's wrong
jay bill is here on the rich eisen show
from the worldwide leader in sports and
before we just uh finish up with the
tournament once again
boy you were the first person i thought
of on friday
uh i made a little bit of a meal of this
as a michigan guy
uh but you were the first person i
thought of when i heard the pr
read the press release from michigan
state and rocket mortgage
that the team will be known it doesn't
have to be known and broadcast but i
guess it'll be emblazoned on the court
or somewhere in the breslin center
msu spartans presented by rocket
mortgage what did you think of when you
heard of that
particularly well i have i had some fun
with it because i think it is really
funny
um but it's really no big deal i mean uh
somebody grabbed that i think it was
yahoo sports grabbed that out of the
rocket mortgage press release yes
but it's pretty standard stuff about
sponsorship
and the the university making money and
all that you know it's the same as nick
saban standing on his podium with a
coca-cola and a dasani water in front of
him
uh you know i didn't get paid for that i
shouldn't have i should have just said a
sponsored
beverage um yeah i'm i'm losing money
here
it's all content jay it's all good
but you know that their michigan state
was a little sensitive about it at first
but it's really no big deal we were just
made we were just
having a laugh at the system not
necessarily at them they were just the
ones in the crosshairs for the moment
it'll be somebody else soon you know
because everything is for sale including
the players
and uh it's just it's kind of laughable
at times but i've never
look look as i i said on friday's show
that i you know obviously under armour
you know in maryland and nike in in
oregon and
you know uh obscenely rich alums
making business deals with their schools
and and
and sports programs is nothing new but
presented by that's that's just
something that it
that i think that's what got everyone's
attention because
it's it literally sounds like
something's brought to you by
it's a flat out commercial you know what
i'm saying like that's the
that might be the difference maker well
it was just the wording of it
because what when we just even when they
have a post game press conference though
it's the it's the logo the university
and
rocket mortgage um and and that you know
that happens at duke it happens that
north carolina happens everywhere
they've got their sponsor behind them
so it's all a big money grab i don't
blame them the problem isn't the money
that they're making or the revenue
they're generating that's all fine i
have zero problem with that it's that
you're cutting out
only one segment of of of the uh the
population that being
the athlete and you know what's funny
during the pandemic rich
is is i was asking is you know people
are saying yeah oh the kid they
keep calling kids the kids want to play
the kids want to play i'm like okay
well well tell me what other students uh
what other student has a university put
on an airplane in the past 12 months
for a university function anyone
like they haven't you know this is for
money we're doing this for money
and and it's great that the competition
is great
it's it's a great thing for the players
it's great thing for the coaches great
thing for the broadcasters it's great
but but the world wouldn't spin off its
axis if the players made money
and we didn't stop watching the olympics
when they could make money
we don't we don't care where how much
money tiger woods makes
you know we don't care whether you know
whether amateur golfers are getting
uh manufacturers deals uh for their
equipment and their
apparel nobody cares and they won't care
in college sports
and so like i don't know why the ncaa
keeps fighting this fight and they're
going to fight it on march 20 march 31st
before the united states supreme court
um it it just baffles it baffles me that
we're making this kind of money
and then we're telling the telling the
the players that
if you take an extra sandwich you know
we're gonna we're gonna burn you at the
stake
i can't you just it's crazy well i gotta
say you can do something for me jay
because you're in a position to do this
calling games and talking about these
games is it for a michigan state player
instead of saying what they're
shooting from the field you could call
it an annual percentage rate
um you know what i mean like their apr
from the field is fifty percent
like that would be fantastic if you did
that oh i
can do that i can do that in a heartbeat
and
especially the rich eisen show brought
to you by a hoopkey
that's it here you go they go well you
know i i would like to think something a
little bit more expensive than that but
i understand where you're going on that
it can be it can be any car you want it
could be a maserati it could be whatever
you want you know what i mean like if
i was a night if one if college hooped
you tonight
i do remember that that's like a 20 year
old reference which is
insane in its own self that was the rake
the raker ruth trial
uh you were reporting that that a
witness had said that he had gotten a
hooptie which is which is a
car and uh and then you had to do a
promo for our show next which at the
time was called college hoops tonight
and you call it
you said uh coming up next college
you know i'm sure management cringed
when i made that reference but it's all
good
uh j bill is here on the rich eisen show
okay before i let you go
uh you picked every game of the
tournament on espn.com what are you
hoping to
to hit what's your hit rate that you're
hoping for uh predicting
every game in the ncaa tournament jay
every year it's 100
i don't see why it wouldn't be this year
uh even in the bubble so
you know i i account for every variable
so there's never a problem the only
problem there is
is uh how it affects the gambling lines
because uh so many people are gonna win
okay so everyone should go check it out
he's a 100 percent
i feel like now like i should give like
an 888 number for the lock
the lock of the first round with jay
bilas i feel like i should do that
right now you look at that it's like
that that back to the future movie where
the guy had the magazine
the future almanac sports almanac and he
could bet everything because he knew the
outcome
you know the outcome now i do know that
i do know that uh and as a matter of
fact uh
normally sometimes you would know the
outcome but i also saw on your twitter
feed today at jay bilas as i let you go
sir
uh what uh what one seeds are uh
against 16 seeds in the history of the
ncaa tournament one thirty nine and one
you got an interesting response
jay to your team yeah um umbc said they
hadn't heard that news
and uh and uh i i think they should have
just read the paper because i'm pretty
sure it was covered look at that back
and forth
they're they're gonna they will live
that they will dine out on that for
forever forever more and they should it
may be the only one ever
actually the 16 seeds fared better when
they first came
onto the radar uh back in 1985 uh the
the games were a lot closer the margins
are much wider now
139 and 1 is your final uh is your final
tally going into this uh tournament
jay thank you for the call appreciate it
let's chat uh i think we're
you were kind enough to say you will
chat with us after the national
championship game so i will chat with
you then
looking forward to it thanks richard you
gotta it's jay bilas right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here